Hi, my name is Victor Tsaran.
And I work as a technology
program manager at Google.
At Google I work on making sure
that the products we create
are accessible to the audience
of our diverse users,
regardless of their ability or
impairment.
Modern web technologies make
it very easy for a developer
to create a website that's difficult for
someone who is blind to use.
If a user has no vision, it's quite
likely they would be using a screen
reader, which is a software
that allows them to
hear the information displayed on the
screen via a text to speech synthesizer.
They may also be using Braille which
allows them to feel the on-screen
text with their fingers
when using braille display.
Many websites are visual in their
nature and lack keyboard navigation
which is essential for blind people to
be able to navigate through the content.
In general, it is safe to assume
that there are more people with
visual impairments,
that is people who have some sight,
as opposed to people who
are completely blind.
There are also people
with low visual acuity.
And they may be using
large print text or
magnification when using the computer,
for example,
my friend Laura uses magnification
with text to speech,
as well as various
color contrast options.
>> Let's meet up at the coffee shop.
I can order something for
you, iced coffee okay?
>> And I haven't mentioned
people with poor color vision
who may have difficulty distinguishing
red and green or blue and yellow.
This accounts for
9% of male and 1% of female.
We may also find ourselves
with temporary challenges,
such as when trying to use a computer in
the sun or looking at a dodgy projector.
Whenever accessibility
comes up in a conversation,
people tend to picture someone
who is blind like myself.
But there actually more impairments
to think about and consider.
There is a huge number of people
with motor or dexterity impairments.
Such users may be using
only the keyboard, head or
eye tracking software,
switches, voice dictation etc.
Someone may have a broken wrist,
broken track pad, or
simply riding the Shaker train.
By catering to users with
permanent dexterity impairments,
we ensure a great experience for
everyone.
There are also users
with hearing impairments.
For example, some may be completely
deaf, yet others have some hearing.
The content that uses sound should
provide some kind of visual alternative.
For example, a messenger app could
be using a flashing alert as well
as sound notifications.
There are also users with
cognitive impairments, for
example ADD, dyslexia or autism.
These users may require
diverse accommodations,
such as zooming the screen to make
it easier to read the content,
or minimal design to minimize
destruction and cognitive load.
We can all probably relate to
feeling stressful or cognitive load.
So improving the experience for users
with cognitive impairments makes it so
much better experience for
everybody else.
In summary, accessibility is
really about making sure that
the content and
the websites we create is
usable to people with various
impairments or abilities.